dernière séance plénière pour les 18
membres du conseil municipal des jeunes
de montigny le bretonneux
après deux ans de mandat ils dressent
leur bilan de cette expérience citoyenne
on a amené lui ni dès le tournage tout
pub le bled
le rallye citoyen et on a fait toutes
les commémorations du 11 novembre et du
8 mai un mandat qui lui a donné le goût
de l'engagement ilan ne se représentera
pas mais il compte bien intégrer un
collectif de jeunes défenseurs du climat
pour leur vie future c'est ce qu'on
disait c'est très enrichissant et sacré
en fait une ville où chacun peut
s'impliquer à sa mesure sur différents
sujets c'est plus passionnant le cmj
existe depuis 30 ans à montigny le
bretonneux mener à bout des projets
s'impliquer dans la vie locale et
citoyenne
c'est aussi un moyen de prendre
confiance en soi et grandir entre jeunes
encadrés par une coordinatrice
j'ai appris déjà m'affirmer ce qu'avant
j'étais assez timide j'ai pu partager
mes idées avec les autres sans avoir
spécialement à être coupés on a tous pu
s'entendre vraiment sont deux années qui
ont été pleines de jouer à plein de
bonheur plein d'apprentissage et c'est
qu'elles sont deux années qui m'ont
beaucoup plu manon compte bien
renouveler l'expérience et présentera sa
candidature pour un prochain mandat
ouvert à tous les jeunes du cm2 à la
seconde vous avez jusqu'au 25 novembre
pour remplir votre dossier et leur
apporter en mairie ou au pôle jeunesse
à vous ensuite de convaincre durant
votre campagne avant les élections qui
se dérouleront dans les établissements
scolaires de la ville du 9 au 13
décembre
[Applaudissements]